- Maybe we'd be just better off
if we gave it to everybody
and then in a month it would be over!
- Oh, my God.
There is so much misinformation going on
with this novel coronavirus,
it boggles my mind.
And it's causing people to
panic, make bad decisions.
My patients are confused.
So, I decided to make this video
and take on misinformation.
By watching some clips,
reading some articles with you,
and really understanding where
the misinformation comes from.
- We have contained this,
I won't say airtight, but
pretty close to airtight.
We've done a good job
in the United States.
- No, we did not contain it.
No, it's not even remotely
close to airtight.
Yes, we've made some steps
in the right direction
of trying to quarantine people
and we should applaud out
public health professionals.
But to say on national television
that this is contained?
No!
Especially February 25th, my God.
The numbers are still gonna
go up tremendously in the US
as more testing kits become available.
So, no.
Not airtight, but also
still no reason to panic.
- [Reporter] Are you taking this
too seriously wearing a mask right now?
- Look, members of Congress
are human Petri dishes.
We fly through the dirtiest airports,
we touch everyone we meet.
So if anyone's gonna get coronavirus,
it's totally gonna be Congress.
(stuttering)
- I'm at a loss for words here.
He's wearing a gas mask.
This isn't even what we
wear in the medical setting
when we're dealing with someone
who has the coronavirus.
This has to be for some
kind of shock value
and clearly I'm watching it on TMZ,
so he got the nation's attention.
You're a lawmaker, you're
the person we look to
to give us accurate
information to protect us.
Take off the gas mask, act like a human.
Get educated on the subject,
stop with the misinformation.
- Think about how the
world would be if you tried
to quarantine everybody because
of the generic-type flu.
Now, I'm not saying this
is the generic-type flu,
but maybe we'd be just better off
if we gave it to everybody
and then in a month it would be over
because the mortality
rate of this probably
isn't gonna be any different
if we did it that way.
- This is what happens when you have
a politician or economist,
I don't even know what his position is,
speak on a subject that
they're not experts in.
This is horribly wrong.
No, we shouldn't just gather everyone up
and give them the novel coronavirus.
That is a horrible idea
and a horrible sentiment.
Not only because it's cruel
because people are going to die,
but it's not scientifically warranted.
Let me explain.
Yes, we don't quarantine
everybody to prevent
to spread of the flu
because we have things
to prevent the flu, to treat the flu.
We have medicines that if you get the flu,
we can reduce complication rates.
We can shorten the course,
it's called oseltamivir.
We also have the flu
shot that if you get it,
it prevents the spread of the flu
or if you still get the flu,
you'll have a milder case.
For the novel coronavirus,
we have no such thing.
So we absolutely need
to slow this thing down
by quarantining individuals
so that we can get these
medications made, approved,
safety tested, do the same
thing with the vaccine
so that unnecessarily we
don't cost people their lives.
The whole purpose of herd
immunity or community protection
is to make sure everyone gets vaccinated
so we can protect those
who can't get vaccinated.
Now, in this case, we
don't have a vaccine,
but we can still provide herd immunity
or community protection
by quarantining those who are sick.
Because, yes, while me
as a healthy 30-year-old
if I get this novel coronavirus,
it looks like my lethality
rate is gonna be quite low.
But for someone like my
father, who's age 65,
that's not the same story.
- What I don't like in life
is that a very serious thing,
a football manager's opinion is important.
I don't understand it, I
really don't understand it.
They can ask you, you're
exactly the same role that I am
and it's not important
what famous people say.
No, we have to speak about the
things in the right manner.
(clapping)
- Why did it take a
football manager to come on
and make the most rational statement
about this novel coronavirus.
Oh, my goodness.
All it takes is if you don't
know and you're not an expert,
allow the experts to speak on it.
The last thing I wanna
see is one more picture
of Gwyneth Paltrow wearing
a fancy, $200 face mask
claiming that that's how
she stays safe because
she was in the movie "Contagion"
and she knows what's up.
No, that's goop.
And when I say goop, I meant poop.
I'm really disappointed
at written media as well.
It used to mean something
to be a journalist
where you really took on that oath
to deliver the truth to the public
so they can make the best
decisions for themselves.
And lately what I've been seeing,
especially on digital media,
is websites and websites specifically that
have a really good reputation
create click worthy, buzzy articles
that really are inciting panic
and scaring people more than anything.
Here I'm holding an article from Nat Geo,
which was my favorite
magazine growing up as a kid.
The science in it really fueled my passion
for learning about the human body.
This article's called
Here's what coronavirus does to the body.
Already very clicky.
Okay, I'm with it.
Let's see what the subheadline is.
"From blood storms to honeycomb lungs,
here's an organ-by-organ look
at how COVID-19 harms humans."
Okay, okay.
You're trying to grab attention.
Okay, I'm with it.
Let's see where we go from here.
"The disease can cast a storm
over the whole human body."
That sounds really scary.
"COVID-19 epidemic has killed
more than 1,800 people,
surpassing the SARS death
toll in a matter of weeks."
But then they explain that the death rate
for COVID-19 appears
to be a fifth of SARS.
Scary sentence, followed by legitimate
scientific quote that's not so scary.
"Last Thursday was nearly a 50% jump
relative to the prior day,
and a tally has since
increased by another 13,000."
Scary.
Oh, but "this leap reflects
a change in the way
Chinese authorities are
diagnosing infections instead of
a massive shift in the
scope of the outbreak.
If this outbreak continues to spread,
there's no telling how
harmful it could become."
There's so many unknowns with this virus,
but to theorize that everything could be
the worst form of itself
doesn't help anybody.
It fuels fear, panic.
It's the reason why toilet paper is
off the shelves in so many countries.
Why hand sanitizer's $80 for
a little container on Amazon.
This is why!
Then they get to the meat of the article
where they actually talk
about each organ system
and how it's affected.
The lungs, ground zero.
"Even if death doesn't occur,
some patients survive with
permanent lung damage.
SARS punchee holes in the lungs,
giving them a honeycomb-like appearance.
And these lesions are present in those
afflicted by novel coronavirus, too."
82% of these cases are mild.
As we learn more, for example,
where there have been 150,000 or so
cases tested in South Korea,
they found that the
fatality rate is 0.6% there.
Not the 3.4% that the WHO
talked about in China,
which is to say that we
need to learn more about it.
But to talk about it as if
it's creating honeycomb lungs,
or blood storms, or affecting the stomach
because SARS and MERS
affected the stomach.
Why write this article?
I don't know what purpose this serves
outside of getting clicks and
trying to get people scared.
This is not useful Nat Geo,
you're not helping anyone with this.
There's a reason why I keep saying
"alert, not anxious" in my videos
and it's because we need
people to not panic.
We need them to be prepared,
we need them to be ready
for when the numbers go up
'cause they most certainly will go up.
In fact, here in the United States,
the numbers are gonna
skyrocket in the next few days.
But that's simply because
we're testing people,
not 'cause there's this
new giant outbreak.
There's also something to be said about
the media's obsession
with changing numbers.
- 100,000 confirmed cases.
3,300 deaths.
230 known cases.
21 US states.
12 people have died.
- Yes, numbers are gonna go up.
This is a virus that spreads.
No matter how much we try and quarantine,
there's still gonna be
spread of this virus.
The idea is that we try and control it
to the best of our abilities,
but know there'll be fluctuations
in the daily numbers.
That's why I recommend not
looking every single day
and not being scared by
headlines that we see on Twitter
that are like, "Oh, my God.
Governor Wolf says there are now
two confirmed cases in Pennsylvania."
There's gonna be a lot of confirmed cases
in Pennsylvania, in the US.
Especially as we get more
testing kits available
to the doctors and nurses
on the front lines.
But that's okay.
We should know how many
cases are out there,
we wanna know so we can properly calculate
the lethality rate to
get more information,
to study these people, to maybe
put them in clinical trials.
But the more the media shows
breaking news, alert, outbreak warning
the more we're gonna panic
and the more we're gonna make
bad decisions with bad information.
And I urge the media,
please be responsible in your reporting.
Get a doctor on board,
get a researcher on board
to talk about what's going on
with this novel coronavirus.
Because when we have
unqualified individuals
talk on this subject, it creates panic.
Patients come in and take appointments
from those who are truly sick
because they wanna get tested
for a condition they
shouldn't be tested for.
So, let's ease the misinformation
out of our headlines.
Let's talk about the facts
and let trusted sources
like the CDC and WHO guide us properly
as we move forward
throughout this pandemic.
I put together a playlist of all my
coronavirus videos right here
and I put together a playlist of my
Reddit thread videos where
doctors discuss some of
their most difficult
cases, embarrassing cases
and I think they're both worth a watch.
Which one are you clicking on
to stay happy and healthy?